[Música]
Más allá de las divisiones que genera en
Italia la figura de Silvio berlusconi es
determinante en el país con nueve años
en el poder siendo Primer Ministro fue
la persona que duró más tiempo liderando
el país desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial
y un personaje que le dio fuerza a la
derecha italiana pero no estuvo exento
de polémicas enfrentó acusaciones de
fraude fiscal y rumores que nunca se
pudieron confirmar de supuestos
financiamientos por parte de la mafia
italiana sus fiestas bunga bunga en la
que prostituía menores de edad se
conocieron en todo el mundo y aunque se
retiró de su cargo En noviembre de 2011
siguió influyendo en la política y en
los medios italianos especialmente a
través de su partido Forza Italia todo
esto hasta el momento de su muerte el 12
de junio veamos el siguiente informe en
el que conoceremos los detalles de su
vida
amado o detestado con Silvio berlusconi
no hubo nunca términos medios permaneció
al frente de la política italiana por
más de dos décadas sirviendo como Primer
Ministro en cuatro gobiernos durante 17
años y dejando tras así un legado de
controversia no fueron los múltiples
escándalos sexuales sino la crisis
económica y sus propios problemas
legales los que finalmente acabaron con
la era berlusconia en Italia nació en
1936 en una familia de clase media de
Milán Se ganó un nombre como cantante de
un club nocturno pero después estudiar
leyes en la universidad Amazon una
inmensa fortuna como promotor
inmobiliario en 1978 dirigió sus
ambiciones hacia los medios italianos
lanzó una compañía de televisión por
cable Y utilizando sus conexiones
políticas la llevó a ser el más grande
imperio mediático del país eso combinado
con la propiedad del club de fútbol hace
Milan lo convirtió en un nombre familiar
así fue como verlos con Y puso la mira
en la política definiéndose como liberal
moderado en 1993 formó su partido forts
a Italia que un año después ganaba las
elecciones generales a pesar de ser
multimillonario encontró la forma de
conectar con el votante común su primer
gobierno colapsó después de siete meses
pero verlos con y permaneció en
perturbable volvió a ser Primer Ministro
en 2001 y aunque salió del gobierno en
2006 ganó las elecciones para un tercer
y último mandato dos años después con el
tiempo los escándalos sexuales y las
acusaciones de corrupción le pasaron
factura las fiestas en su Villa
vulgarmente conocidas como las bunga
bunga llegaron a los titulares de todo
el mundo y dañaron su popularidad en
casa en noviembre de 2011 la maltrecha
economía de Italia fue la gota que
rebosó el vaso en el pico de la crisis
de deuda de la eurozona y renunció las
esperanzas de regreso Se frustraron en
2013 cuando fue condenado por fraude
fiscal expulsado del parlamento y se le
prohibió volver a postularse ese mismo
año fue hallado culpable de pagar por
tener sexo con una menor una condena
revocada en 2014 pero la salida de la
política no fue total en 2022 su partido
Forza Italia formó parte de una alianza
de ultraderecha que llevó al poder a
Georgia meloni a pesar de décadas de
altibajos y luego los coman y mantuvo el
apoyo de miles e italianos que han
admirado su resiliencia su controvertida
faceta pública y su liderazgo político
multipristo Cuál es Entonces el legado
que deja Silvia o berlusconi en Italia
para debatir este tema nos acompaña
desde firence Italia la doctora
constanza germanina académica del
instituto europeo universitario y en
dublín Irlanda está Stefano angeleri
profesor de derechos humanos de la
facultad de la jurisprudencia de la
Universidad del Rosario en Colombia y
también de Queens y University belfast a
ellos bienvenidos y a ustedes nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
sus comentarios y preguntas en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram donde estamos como
arroba franz24 raya al piso es los
leemos con la etiqueta hashtag el debate
f-24 y a mí me encuentran como arroba
María claguirre no olviden además que
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
están disponibles en Apple podcast
Spotify deezer y TuneIn
constanza le quiero dar la bienvenida a
usted para comenzar este debate
constanza Germain Gracias por
acompañarnos y la pregunta para
introducir esta discusión Bajo su
perspectiva Cuál es el legado que deja
Silvio berlusconi
Gracias a ustedes por la invitación el
legado que deja si veo berlusconi es un
legado muy poderoso y en el mismo tiempo
es un legado que
y se ve hoy en Italia
está dividiendo muchísimo la población
es Alguien que ha sido detestado por una
parte importante de la nación pero que
pude convencer una proporción de
personas muy importantes durante 30 años
entonces hoy como puede ser lo saben hay
una polémica muy fuerte sobre la
decisión de darle a ver los Connie
una
funerales oficiales del estado y poner
un luto nacional por su muerte y esto es
muy significativo de la de los que deja
el país
Stefano le quiero dar la bienvenida a
usted y preguntarle qué opina de este
punto que nos Comenta constanza sobre el
hecho de que haberlos con y le vayan a
dar un funeral oficial con todas las
pompas estatales Buenas tardes María
Clara Buenas tardes profesora constanza
Eh sí como mencionaba la profesora
constanza efectivamente un legado
importante y claramente la figura de
continúa siendo
excepcional en la política italiana
y hasta después de morir de fallecer
porque efectivamente los funerales de
estado se dan a figuras importantes de
la
del país pero el luto nacional conlleva
la cancelación de los compromisos de los
miembros del gobierno en agenda la
bandera medio bajada en las embajadas
potencialmente Un minuto de silencio en
las escuelas
entonces
muy controversial sobre todo por un
hombre como mencionaba no y importantes
políticos del político político una
política muy importante el país de los
Cindy
que un político tan controversialla
sobre todo cuanto a la cosificación de
la mujer que se le dé tanta
una una un trato de este tipo
es efectivamente
indicativo del legado que deja la
sociedad italiana o sea 30 años
de perroscópio en la política italiana
no se cancelan en
en pocos meses no se cancelan tampoco
con con su fallecimiento sino que dejan
huellas en el país desde un punto de
vista cultural y claramente político
normativo y vamos a hablar más adelante
de la cosificación de la mujer que usted
señala y que también
se vio representada a través de los
medios de comunicación que fundó
berlusconi pero antes le quiero
preguntar señor Stefano A qué se debe
Entonces si fue una figura detestada
como lo decía constanza a qué se debe
que haya sido el Primer Ministro que más
años gobernó en el país
es una pregunta muy compleja y
pudiéramos demorarnos muchísimo tiempo
en contestarla
Y seguramente fue un líder muy
carismático fue una en un periodo
particular de la historia italiana
transformó un partido en una empresa
utilizó el
la la desconfianza de la población
italiana en un periodo particular hacia
la política hacia lo público a su
beneficio
me gustaría si vos mencionar un discurso
que he leído recientemente sobre que
hizo en el 2009 a los a los jóvenes de
su partido
él mencionaba que los italianos me aman
me aman porque soy uno de ellos porque
nací pobre me construí solo me interesa
el fútbol me me gusta divertirme y sobre
todo me gustan las mujeres así como
debería ser para para cualquier hombre
para cualquier italiano Entonces él
hablaba a una parte de la sociedad a una
parte de la sociedad italiana que estaba
y que probablemente sigue espero yo en
de manera menor después de muchos años
digamos durante estos 30 años de
participación política
hablaba a un determinado público pero
este determinado Público con su
capacidad de comunicativas con su
excelente capacidad de comunicadora y de
vendedor
en esto era y en eso nacía
consiguió convencer muchísima gente no
solamente masas pero también élites
pero a pesar de que venía de la clase
media como usted bien lo señaló poco a
poco construyó todo un imperio y no solo
mediático sino también político al punto
que según la revista Forbes fue el
tercer personaje más rico en toda Italia
constanza usted Cómo cree que siendo un
multimillonario lograba conectar con esa
clase más popular de Italia
es alguien muy inteligente que que
verlos con y llegó a hacer Pero
déjeme decir algo de su 30 años en la
escena política italiana
Esto se debe cuanto menos un pocos
también al hecho que cuando él entró a
la política en el novante a tres cambió
la ley electoral italiana que
hasta ese tiempo había
determinado una fragmentación partida
muy importante y unas
mayorías y unos gobiernos que seguían
cambiando muy seguido después de este
año eso no se ocurrió más y y por eso
también ver los Connie pudo
tener el poder
durante muchos años
una otra cosa que que se me parecía
importante decir es que
este su partido de la libertad Esto es
algo que le ha ayudado a conectarse con
con el público porque es un partido que
al final del siglo pasado
se destacó de las ideologías no de la
ideologías de la derecha y de la
izquierda porque el partido de la
libertad de berlusconi Finalmente se
presentó como un partido liberal de las
libertades algo que faltaba a Italia y
que sigue faltando en ese momento porque
la escena política desde hace unos años
está completamente
ocupada por la derecha y finalmente este
hecho de los
funerales de Estados y el luto nacional
bueno es algo que está muy controvertido
hoy pero también yo lo veo como una
decisión política casi natural por
fuerzas política de derecha y extrema
derecha que están en el gobierno en este
momento y quieren marcar un punto
ideológico y político
dándosele a verlos con y una
un funeral de estado y un día de luto
Entonces
está algo que personalmente
no es con que personalmente no estoy de
acuerdo pero políticamente comprendo
decisión
primera ministra que Italia se hace a
llamar Primer Ministro porque gestiones
de género de la derecha todavía sigue
combatiendo batallando
por eso esta decisión es una decisión
política Clara y que sirve al gobierno
como política identitaria ideológica hoy
y también eso mostraría la influencia
que tuvo Silvio berlusconi después de
que dejó el poder por lo menos de manera
directa estefano Cómo resumir el impacto
de berlusconia en la política italiana
después de que dejó de ser ministro en
Bueno
después de 2011 efectivamente
la verrusconi que que había sido muy
directo y también muy extremo en algunas
en algunas en muchas ocasiones en
públicas
se ha convertido en una figura más
moderada y
hasta guiño el ojo a hacer tu electorado
ambientalista en los últimos años
también por razones personales
guiño el ojo a un electorado
lgbtiq Blas sobre todo el lgbt el eje
pero sí a mantenerse se ha dado cuenta
que efectivamente en esta en esta en
este grupo de gobierno que le ponía al
lado de salvini melón y con
composiciones bastante extremas en la
también estaba consciente de sus
intereses también económicos entonces
también a nivel internacional y entonces
su papel se ha se ha convertido en un
papel un poquito más más medido más
medido más en línea con su idea de
moderación como se llamaba como se
dejaba llamar más moderado pero no ha
dejado de de participar políticamente en
la escena política italiana eso no
Y sobre todo
hasta el último momento hasta el momento
que hasta hace poco más de un año
esta esta imagen un poquito menos
extrema sirvió también porque por por la
intención la idea de
de ser presidente de la república
italiana que como figura institucional
y
más medida cosa que no pasó pero pero sí
fue un poco más extremo digamos
y antes de la aparición de Georgia la
actual primera ministra como diríamos en
español o el actual Primer Ministro como
lo dirían en Italia y nos cuenta
constanza antes de esto se puede decir
que berlusconi tenía una postura
bastante de derecha constanza Cómo es
esta relación entre la derecha y la
extrema derecha en Italia y qué papel
tiene berlusconi
bueno en mi opinión
al día de hoy
la relación bueno la derecha que en
Italia es una derecha extrema
en particular
después de la muerte de berlusconi no
existe una figura de derecha moderada A
Italia Nunca más
[Música]
en los últimos años perluzconi sufrió la
el
figuras como la de Georgia melón y Mateo
salvini que le
[Música]
han ocupado el espacio Público con ideas
de derecha contra las migrantes y
también
contra las personas el GB de Plus qué
verlos Connie no tenía el mismo porque
sí era machista pero no no diría yo que
era un homófobo O transofo de verdad
creo creía en la en la libertad y en
todos los tipos de libertades en
particular
sexuales
Es verdad que este el hecho que el año
pasado pudo presentarse seriamente en
consideración para ser presidente de la
república fue algo
que sorprendió la mayoría de los
italianos porque
hace De verdad unos años
era Era una figura que la mitad de
Italia no podía no podía absolutamente
pensar como una figura neutral y Súper
partes la que sería idealmente la figura
del presidente de la república tenemos
no podemos olvidar y yo no puedo olvidar
y toda mi generación no puede olvidar
cuando se llenaron la plazas de Italia
porque ver los cómics
por por la condamia de de verlos Connie
finalmente en los años
cuando finalmente fue condado por fraude
fiscal Entonces es una figura el debate
de hoy
por gente que como yo
tenía 15 años cuando llegó en la escena
política es un debate como que nos
sorprende muchísimo es algo que nunca
nos esperamos de escuchar
y esta faceta del político no se puede
desprender la faceta como empresario
porque fue el dueño del Milan y también
fundó el que es hoy por hoy el complejo
mediático más grande de Italia mediaset
y creó varios medios de comunicación
como telemilano en 1974 y canales chinco
o Canal 5 en
1980 Stefano Cuál es el impacto que deja
la sociedad Italiana la figura de
berlusconi de el empresario
el impacto más que el empresario digamos
el impacto de sus medios de comunicación
es enorme o sea
yo tenía 10 años Cuando entró en
política
y yo fui
o sea tipo verlos representaba la
televisión Privada de perros con y eran
los dibujos animados
en la televisión de berlus emitían
novelas que hasta que el momento en
Italia no habían llegado y tenía
compañía una buena parte de la población
que lo encontraba de entretenimiento
en los años 80
aparecían mujeres semidesnudas en la
televisión muchos colores cuando la
televisión de estado era una televisión
bastante
conservadora diría yo bastante grisa Y
entonces esto guiñaba Al ojo a este
hombre machista
entonces realmente un impacto un impacto
muy importante un Impacto
que ha marcado generaciones y desde
Entonces digamos que la televisión y
también los medios de comunicaciones han
sido utilizados durante durante su
primera su primera campaña electoral
muchísimo presentadores
que tenían mucho mucho apego con la
población
la verdad Y qué tipo les habían como
mostrado
a favor de la de la votación para
berlusconi entonces realmente uno
utiliza no solo una un impacto cultural
pero también una utilización del medio
comunicativo
que beneficiar a sus intereses sus
intereses también político al final
usted señala un punto muy interesante
que también comparte un artículo del
medio farming publicy que decía que
precisamente a través de los programas
que emitían cadenas como Canal 5 se
estaba configurando el papel y el rol de
la mujer en Italia como usted bien lo
dice mostraban a la mujer en paños
interiores con poca ropa y además las
presentadoras poco presentaban o poco
decían Más allá de unas cuantas frases y
decía este artículo o algo con lo que
usted parece coincidir que todo esto
contribuyó a que Italia hoy por hoy siga
siendo una sociedad sumamente machista y
de hecho en el índice de brecha de
género que saca cada año el foro
económico mundial Italia está en el
puesto 68 en el mundo por debajo de
países como Kenia uganda El Salvador
Perú chile solo por mencionar algunos
constanza usted coincide en este punto
en que los medios que fundó berlusconi
fueron determinantes para la brecha de
género que existe hoy en Italia
yo creo que sí tengo que confesar algo
mi investigación académica me ocupo
mucho de igualdad de género en Italia y
empecé a ocuparme de este tema
al momento en que regresé a Italia
después de 15 años trabajando en otros
países de Europa y América y eso no es
por caso es lo de la igualdad de género
mujer y hombres pero también de la
igualdad de género con personas no
binarias es un tema que se siente
se siente muy muy fuerte acá
Aunque
haya hoy una una jefa de gobierno
una mujer a la al gobierno
investigadoras investigadores que
estudian
la historia de
la igualdad de género a Italia dicen
claramente que por ejemplo
diferentemente que España hay Italia
hubo este esta interrupción del Progreso
de emancipación femenina después de del
Progreso de los años setenta
que
qué pasó sustancialmente cuando a
berlusconi empezó a
invadir el espacio cultural con sus
televisiones en los años 80 y 90 y yo
creo que esto es verdad Pero algo más
tengo que quiero decir es este el efecto
de la concentración mediática de
que llegó a tener ver los Connie con sus
televisiones
es también el hecho que
no haya a Italia todavía
un pluralismo
un verdadero pluralismo de información
la información mediática en la
televisión Ah no no en los nuevos medios
de comunicación pero en la televisión
sigue siendo muy dominante
políticamente
y esto pasa en los medios públicos que
están normalmente al Servicio del
gobierno y en los medios privados que
durante muchos años fueron al servicio
diverlusconi y de su agenda política y
uno creo que él tuvo también una agenda
cultural Clara pero la agenda política
sí vemos entonces los impactos de las
agendas políticas y cultural que lideró
Silvio berlusconi en Italia constanza Le
quiero preguntar muy brevemente para
comenzar a introducirnos en todos los
escándalos que protagonizó él como la
prostitución los vínculos presuntos con
La Mafia y la acusación y condena de
fraude fiscal que luego se reversó
Cuáles son los impactos que deja en el
país todos los escándalos que enfrentó
verlos Connie constanza
Cuáles son los
yo tengo que decir que no creo que sean
bastantes creo que verlos Connie y sus
abogados trabajaron muy bien
[Música]
enfrentar las acusaciones de los jueces
y
en el crear
la convicción en el país en una mayoría
de la gente en el país
que los jueces y sus investigaciones
fueron
motivadas políticamente es algo que
verlos siguió diciendo durante toda su
carrera política siguió diciéndolo sobre
toda investigación las que sobre los
escándalos sexuales la sobre la condamia
de fraude fiscal las sobre
las acusación de tener relaciones con La
Mafia y de esta manera yo creo que el
hierro a minimizar
sus
problemas de justicia y que esta
minimización Explica el hecho que hoy en
día el país puede pensar a darle a esta
persona con todo su pasado un funeral de
Estados y un luto nacional fue una
estrategia de defensa extremamente que
tuvo un éxito sorprendente y está
minimización judicial como usted La
Llama por esto es que le llamaban Don
teflón porque Ninguno de los casos que
tenía en contra lograban progresar y
también esto le ha valido comparaciones
con el expresidente estadounidense
Donald Trump sin embargo berlusconi se
negaba rotundamente a dicha comparación
estefano Usted cree que son comparables
estos dos personajes o como defendía
verlos con y no tienen nada parecido
hombre nada parecido no pero es verdad
que vienen en dos
aparecen en este mundo digamos podríamos
llamarle populistas pero claro que tipo
la diferencia de veinte años de
distancia la toma del poder tiene algún
tipo de diferencias no O sea tipos
estamos en mundos completamente
diferentes veo
en este momento la Menciona los 35 casos
penales a los que se enfrentó y concordo
con la profesora constanza fueron de
verdad
Muy bien trabajado por parte de su
equipo legal una sola condena Y
muchísimas prescripciones entonces Hay
muchísimas actividades dilatorias de los
de los de los abogados
para obtener este resultado
y francamente
el claro tipo se encuentran muchas
similitudes digamos con sobre todo con
la modalidad no yo creo que tipo es muy
importante el mensaje comunicativo aquí
el Donald Trump y tienen una tiene la
capacidad también de convencer a masas
lo cuyos intereses o personas cuyos
intereses no están coincidían con no
coincidan con con sus intereses
con Y tuvo y utilizó los medios para
identificar digamos para para presentar
contratos a los italianos no Entonces
esto estos mensajes de una manera el
mundo público transformado en un
vocabulario privado no
y finalmente realmente el legado que
tiene que tuvo y la fama que tuvo
berlusconi no se no es comparable por
ejemplo a su resultados políticos de lo
que prometió no cumplió la mayor parte
por ejemplo la reducción del 20 30 por
ciento de la imposición fiscal esto no
no
no no lo no lo alcanzó es más
pero sí redujo los impuestos y o anuló
las impuestos de asociación para a
grandes capitales entonces
seguramente tipo estamos hablando de
millonarios estamos hablando de personas
que utilizan la política para también
para para sus beneficios patrimoniales
en esta conjunción y también dialéctica
entre lo privado y lo público el la la
vida personal es y la vida pública que
que se pierde digamos y genera rumores
no se genera mucho rumora y que del del
que mencionaba la profesora constanza
que efectivamente creo que hoy no no
estamos entendiendo realmente todos los
pasos
que brusconi siguió porque si no no
llegaríamos a esa idea de permitirles un
luto nacional estefano y de manera muy
breve usted habla de la dialéctica de
verlos tú cree que luego de su muerte
queda algún personaje similar en Italia
ha sido un personaje
que duró en la en la escena política
italiana durante 30 años en este momento
no creo que
que haya personajes con con esa talla no
O sea por ejemplo el privado de se
conocía el que no es de mi interés
francamente pero el privado de los
políticos no se conoce Entonces esta
creación del personaje esta creación de
la casi de un reality show alrededor de
su figura No no no pertenece a la vida
de la mayor parte de los políticos
italianos en este momento hemos podido
ver algo parecido con con saldini el
líder de gobierno pero nada nada
Comparado constanza muy brevemente usted
también considera que no hay una figura
semejante
no no hay y por responder a su pregunta
de antes yo creo que esta dimensión de
enseñar su privado su vida familiar
sus elecciones sus sus
ovnis y etcétera fue una una manera muy
una manera por la cual pudo conectar
también con estos electores estos
ciudadanos que lo votaron durante muchos
años aunque no fueran
personas con tan ricas y con los mismos
intereses que que verlos con una cosa me
marcó hoy
en muchas conversaciones que
que tuve con amigas colegas y etcétera
todas las personas y se trata de mujeres
jóvenes en ese tiempo que trabajaron con
él me hablaron muy bien de él y de su
manera de trabajar con sus colaboradores
colaboradoras y
en en las funciones de dados de estado y
y esto resulta sorprendió claro una
faceta distinta al showman que conocimos
públicamente para cerrar nuestro
programa quiero destacar cinco ideas que
ustedes han mostrado y que hablarían del
personaje de Silvio berlusconi la
primera de ellas es que luego de su
muerte no existe una derecha moderada en
Italia la segunda es que contribuyó a la
brecha de género que existe hoy por hoy
en Italia la tercera es cómo hizo de su
propia vida un reality show y pudo
conectar con diferentes poblaciones en
Italia y la otra es como el contribuyó a
que no haya una pluralidad mediática por
lo menos en la televisión italiana y
finalmente minimizó los problemas de
Justicia que enfrentó Los 35 cargos
penales a manera de conclusión muy
brevemente constanza usted que añadiría
para entender la figura de berlusconi
una pregunta muy muy difícil lo que
tenemos que Añadir Es que yo creo y que
es importante por por
el público internacional es que fue la
primera de una serie de figuras muy
controvertidas en en la política
nacional e internacional es la figura
que viene antes de Trump y la figura que
viene antes de nuevos movimientos
populistas como lo fueron los
cinco estrellas a Italia el primer
experimento de una de una nueva política
que No necesariamente fue una política
que que nos dejó
a mucho muchas cosas positivas el
impulsor entonces de una figura
populista estefano muy probablemente su
conclusión
difícil la conclusión difícil la
conclusión y sobre todo
no
no deja de sorprender
O sea la energía de este hombre hasta el
último momento no salían imágenes de
hace pocos días con la situación de
salud muy muy
comprometida con con
supportchers
entonces realmente un hombre que en un
obstante lo vemos lo habíamos mencionado
durante estos 30 minutos juntos de
extrema muy controversial realmente una
una gran de energía una gran energía en
muchísimas ideas y
y efectivamente
como mencionaba la profesora la
profesora constanza
no toda la sociedad italiana es tiene
una imagen negativa de Bruce o sea
efectivamente los trabajadores la
persona con la que la persona cercana
tienen una imagen diferente la imagen
del doctor del doctor berlusconi y de
una persona extremadamente generosa
Entonces lo debo interrumpir Porque
lastimosamente se nos acaba el tiempo
pero gracias de todas maneras a
constanza hermanin y a Stefano angeleri
por acompañarnos en el debate de hoy
ustedes Gracias por preferir Franz 24
continúen con más información
internacional
[Música]